[Music]
the fury
of the virus illustrates the folly of
war
that is why today i am calling for an
immediate global ceasefire
in all corners of the world millions of
people are caught in war zones
the un says that's preventing an
effective response to the outbreak
a bombed hospital can't treat the sick
the virus spreads when tens of millions
flee violence in africa
the middle east and asia
in march the u.n secretary general
called for a global ceasefire
warring parties i say pull back from
hostilities
put aside mistrust and animosity silence
the guns stop the artillery
and the air strikes
but the world responded by buying more
weapons
and starting new conflicts the pandemic
is set to spark
famine riots instability and civil war
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the coronavirus has weakened governments
and security
forces that's allowed some rebel groups
to flourish
they mostly face the same restrictions
their costs are also rising
but they pass them on to those caught in
the territories they hold
still as dw's sikoto the response isn't
that different to that of some
governments
[Music]
this herd is on its way to the biggest
cattle market in the central african
republic
here in bubui some 42 kilometers from
the capital benghi
where the herds are sold for traders in
this country
it means moving from areas that are
controlled by different
armed groups the coronavirus pandemic is
an additional problem
this trade has complained that many
armed groups have taken advantage of
this health crisis
by leaving huge taxes on them
we face so many difficulties in
transporting our cattle from kagabanduro
to the babui market armed groups attack
our shepherd
before coronavirus the rebels asked each
of our herdsmen to pay between 50 and 80
euros
now they've increased the fee to almost
125 euros
they demand so much money for taxes and
we're all discouraged
hasn't changed much for most people it
is almost impossible to determine who is
infected with the coronavirus or not
during the rainy season people have the
flu or malaria
and that in a country where poverty is
notorious
it is estimated that about 71 percent of
the population live below the
international poverty line
men and women are fighting every day to
get food on the table so far
there is little progress in the country
we meet rodriguez poloco
a young activist he specially criticizes
the government's management of the
pandemic
in the beginning of the corona virus
pandemic we were told that with all the
donations that the government had
received
covered 19 won't be a problem the test
was free for instance
but now we have to pay for the test
almost 30 euros
who can pay that it's an unbearable
situation for central africans
in addition to the security and economic
impact of the corona pandemic in the
central african republic
there are more than 4 800 confirmed
cases
and in the midst of all these the
measures put in place by the authorities
to fight against this virus are no
longer respected in public places
one example of how rebel groups are
ruining people's livelihoods and how
some governments are failing to keep
promises
let's bring in matthias basadow he's
director of the giga institute for
african affairs
has the coronavirus led to more conflict
or unrest in
africa oh
that's a very good question my answer
would be
yes and no there has been some limited
increase in terms of violence
what can be called so-called covet 19
disorder this is mainly when
people riot because of access to uh
to nutrition and so on and so forth or
when there is a political repression by
government authorities
on the whole however you know
large-scale violence has not really
increased
at least that's not what the number tell
us what we believe
is that more massive violence can
uh can happen in the future but only
after a period of incubation
especially when economic consequences
get really
really really bad and when there's poor
management of the resulting conflict
well picking up on those restrictions
you've said there are certain kinds of
conflict that
pandemic restrictions are more likely to
aggravate what sort of conflicts
especially at the beginning you have you
know people are reacting directly
to what the governments are doing for
instance if we have lockdowns
uh you know restrictions social
distancing you know
people might not be happy with because
they they feel they cannot you know get
food on the table as it was mentioned in
the
in the in the report before and that of
course has happened for instance in
south africa where there was a
quiet you know strict lockdown on the
other hand people might be scared that
they are exposed to a higher risk
of of infection for instance
like in the cote d'ivoire when a testing
center was destroyed because people were
scared
however this kind of violence you know
is limited in terms of intensity
uh other forms of violence are more
likely to happen uh
in a more distant future and under
unfavorable circumstances
one specific risk could be when economic
conditions become really bad that
vulnerable minorities especially
migrants might become scapegoats i think
south africa could be an
example of that also in ongoing
conflicts you have a risk of escalation
but again the numbers do not show a
strong increase
as of yet and we should point out here
of course that the
pandemic has tamed some conflicts
yes indeed it has although i would be a
little bit cautious with regard to that
as well
of course uh generally i think natural
resources have the you know
kind of power to bring people together
because there's a common threat and they
rally around the flag you know
stick together rather protesting against
it however this effect you know wanes
after a while and we have seen it also
in the report
that uh some of the people get more and
more dissatisfied
you see that around the world globally a
more
concrete example of a taming effect of
the pandemic was in cameroon
we have a secessionist conflict in the
anglophone part of it
and one rebel group there has announced
a ceasefire explicitly mentioning
the pandemic as a reason and as we speak
now
i don't have very very good information
but uh the government is
secretly negotiating uh with the rebels
so i'm not exactly expecting that the
pandemic will stop the conflict but
there's a window of opportunity here
so how do you get the balance right
containing a virus
locking down an economy and preventing
conflict
actually that's a that's an excellent
question maybe it's the one
trillion uh uh dollar question
if i'm gonna put put it this way because
that's exactly you know the key
challenge
on the one hand you know uh you know
keeping the virus at bay
and on the other hand you know avoid
that you harm the economy
so hard that the medicine will be worse
uh you know than the disease
so and unfortunately you know you want
to restrict the virus we have to
uh we have to uh take measures
that harm the economy and
uh you know what one one idea i have in
this regard is that
you know africa was hit later by the uh
by the virus
and that of course offers the
opportunity that uh
africa can learn from other countries
how to do it the right way
matthias we'll have to leave it there
thank you very much for being on the
show today
yeah thank you so much you're welcome
and time to answer your questions
on the coronavirus here's our science
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
why is vitamin d not being promoted more
since there's the evidence that its
deficiency
compromises the immune system
there's been an ongoing discussion in
the medical research community for
for many months now about whether or not
vitamin d
or or more precisely vitamin d
deficiency
could be playing a role in covid19
outcomes lots of people don't get enough
sunlight
to produce sufficient amounts of it
themselves
which is why claims have multiplied that
supplements of vitamin d
help against sars cove too there's clear
evidence
the micronutrient is important to
healthy
immune system function in other words to
how susceptible you are
to infection in general a recent study
from the university of chicago
went a step further looking at patient
records
the research team there discovered what
they claim is a
clear retrospective link between
vitamin d deficiency in patients and
covet 19
risks the problem is is
is that to prove it we still have to
carry out what are called
randomized trials where where we'd
monitor people
getting enough of the vitamin and and
those with known deficiencies and then
track the groups
to see what happens over time whether
there
are differences in how many people in
the cohorts contract coven 19
and if they do how severe it is
another issue though is if vitamin d
really does prove to be an effective
preventive measure what doses of it
should people
take taken in excessive amounts as a
supplement
it can cause calcium to build up in your
blood and can can even cause
organ damage so there are potential
dangers along
with the upsides but but in general the
experts agreed that taking a supplement
in safe amounts recommended in national
guidelines
can't hurt your health and it might help
it
especially if you have a known vitamin d
deficiency
[Music]
finally in his general audience on
wednesday pope francis said we need to
heal the world from the suffering
highlighted by the pandemic
he said the coronavirus has exposed the
great inequality that reigns in the
world
the inequality of goods healthcare
technology and education
the pontiff called for policies that
reward participation care and generosity
rather than indifference exploitation
and special interests
saying a fair and equitable society is a
healthier one
we will be able to regenerate society
and not return to so-called normality
because this normality was sick also
before the pandemic
a normality of injustice inequality and
environmental degradation